but it's scarier than that
there's a purpose to the growth of all
this kind of
state power and i use that term state
broadly to include
tech and education and all those sorts
of things
and the media notably
the most disturbing story i've seen on
cnn in quite some time
occurred over just the past few days an
18 year old
guy jackson refit turned his dad in to
the fbi
because his dad went to the stop the
steel rally
at at capitol hill like maybe he was
part of the riot i'm not sure
i'm he was certainly around the area and
so this
this kid calls the fbi to turn his dad
in because his dad said hey
if you turn me in you're a traitor i
guess the kid had been threatening to
turn him in or suggested he might turn
him in he says if you turn me in you're
a traitor and you know what happens to
traders
which happens to they get capital
punishment so this kid
calls the fbi gets his father arrested
and then cnn has him on to talk about
the wonderful story now
maybe you're of a of two minds on this
man maybe the kid maybe it was a serious
threat maybe he had to turn his dead in
well i don't know it doesn't sound like
a serious threat
listen to refit tell the story to cuomo
who's lapping it up
i know you love your family and i know
this is hard
so help people understand why did you
feel you had to let authorities know
about what was being done to your father
and what was happening in his own head
um i don't really know how to explain it
it was uh it was just
it just felt like the right thing
regardless of my emotions
and how i felt and how much i loved my
family and my dad
i was worried uh i didn't think he would
actually do anything bad
but um him saying anything even remotely
threatening to me and my sister and
my family and government officials it
was just too much
now listen here this is an important
point that he's making
he's because presumably the reason he
called the
fbi on his dad is because his dad
threatened to kill him right he says
you're you'd be a traitor you know what
happens to traitors
but the kid says right here he doesn't
think his dad would have done anything
bad he doesn't actually think it was a
threat
but he turned his dad into the fbi
anyway his dad since been arrested
why did he do it well he makes clear
it's because they have different
political views
it's been definitely over the past four
years that it's grown
and just snowballed into what my dad's
become now and he's still my father but
he's
he's changed a lot household
he's been more active on his
on the internet and
obviously the militia and the far-right
extremists he's been involved with
recently
he's been a lot more i don't want to say
aggressive
but more uh
more uh scared
would he talk to you about it no
uh i actually never even knew he was
going to dc
until the day he left um i'm
sure it was because of my political
views but i'm not sure
and there there you have it i'm sure
it's because of my political views
presumably this kid is quite left-wing
and then he posted a fundraiser because
his
mother kicked him out of the house for
getting his father arrested and uh
from the picture you know he's wearing
like he's got very long hair he's
wearing a pink hat he's where he
he doesn't look like a uh right
right-wing conservative
i'm i'm not even really attacking this
kid i mean
he's 18 years old i guess he's an adult
and it's wrong to
get your father arrested generally
speaking especially for just being a
republican but uh i'm not attacking this
game my heart kind of breaks for this
kid
and certainly it breaks for the family
the
the sisters and the mother who who the
kid acknowledges he says oh yeah i've
broken their hearts i've totally
destroyed their lives yeah because i got
my dad arrested but i felt like i had to
do it i'd do it again
and chris cuomo that disgusting man
lapping it up so happy oh yeah tell me
more about how you got your dad arrested
because he's so right-wing
yeah tell me oh you had to do it you had
to do it
i i mentioned this whole story not even
to comment on the kid or the dad or or
even chris cuomo
i bring up the story because it
has a lot to do with how the left
operates it actually tells you a lot
about the difference between
the right and the left they begin with
different fundamentally different views
of society
and their political agendas are oriented
according to those premises so
for conservatives the fundamental
building block of society is the family
it's not the individual it's the family
that is the fundamental building block
we are not born as free-floating atoms
flying around in outer space then we
land and through our consent we choose
to join a family it's not how it works
we are born out of an act of love
between our parents
and at a higher level out of the active
love of god our creator who creates the
world through
an act of speech let there be light
and so on and we are born with duties
with obligations with loyalties
we are stewards of ourselves our life
which is a gift from
from our parents as approximate cause
and from god ultimately
and we are stewards of this creation
that's where conservatives begin
the left and i include liberals in this
include libertarians in this
the left libertarian certainly begin
with this idea that the individual is
the building block of society and we
have
we are born primarily to rights and
entitlement and not loyalty and not duty
and not obligation
but i darn it i better get mine all
oriented toward the ultimate liberation
and that liberation
must occur by overcoming the
institutions of society
which now we use the term white
supremacy i guess is the kind it's the
term
du jour it's a fetish idea but you you
hear all the patriarchy is another one
of these
and ultimately the family which is that
bedrock institution it's the smallest
political institution you can have
of multiple people in society
organically
that is why the left is always
attempting to destroy the family
to destroy the family by any means
necessary by redefining the family
by taking power away from the family by
increasing the role of the state this is
why even radical individualists
sometimes become defenders of state
power because if the fundamental unit of
society is the individual
then the only way to do anything
together is by amassing all those
individuals together
which is that that is truly the theory
of fascism and it's in the
true meaning of that word where you
bundle all the sticks together and
in the state and the state is the
highest good and of course
the progressive left has this exalted
view of the state
and may even mainstream liberals haven't
exalted you those are different
scenarios and you're going to see a
whole lot more of this
it's deeply disturbing but this is what
it looks like we talk about it in the
abstract a lot
this is what it looks like on the
granular level and this is going to be a
process that goes on like the lockdowns
according to biden for months and months
and months and months and even
longer if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you